throughout the course of this show
though we are mixing in your top five
wide receivers in the nfl right now is
he elite enough to make that company
absolutely now right now i'm going with
deandre hopkins he is
so consistent great hands the best hands
of all these wide receivers dk metcalf
is just a physical freak you don't want
to jam him you don't want to try to get
tied up with him although jaylen ramsey
did a wonderful job devonte adams he's
missed a consistent he's a big physical
wide receiver you see him stepping up
stephon diggs he continues that i mean
he's the way he's playing he's playing
like he's the best wide receiver
national football league and tyree kill
who doesn't what d defensive back
doesn't go to bed at night
thinking about him and how the heck am i
we're gonna stop this guy because he's
so fast but i mean there's a lot of guys
that should be honorable mention robert
woods is fantastic kenny galladay tyler
boyd keenan allen mike williams mike
evans i mean so many great white really
good wide receivers in this league but i
only had to pick five and you know
deandre hopkins after that performance
and his consistency he's the best wide
receiver in the national football league
yeah wow and he's been doing it for a
long long time like i feel like he's one
of those guys that's just starting to
get his due respect dk metcalf has had
just a wild rise he's just kind of
rocket shipped right to the top which
kind of receiver though scared you most
because i mean you played do you play
the secondary in the nfl for a long long
time was there a certain type of
receiver you mentioned tyreek keeping
guys up at night was there a certain
kind speed size what was it that was
like i hope we don't have to see that
this sunday
so i'm gonna name you two guys jack and
that's a really good question
and dk metcalf okay
big tall big strong physical guy
and tyreek hill
right just a big just a fast guy who am
i more afraid of i'm more afraid of
tyreke hill i'm more afraid of tyreke
hill because he's just so fast and he
puts so much pressure on you and his
routes are excellent routes like he'll
act like he's going across the field and
he'll bend you all the way back and
before you know it you're not keeping up
with a guy that can run a 4-3-4-2 i mean
he just puts so much pressure on a deep
part of the field but let me just say
this about deandre hopkins jack
for so many years and you you probably
remember this for so many years deandre
hopkins had to play with
backup quarterbacks subpar quarterbacks
he was still putting up numbers he was
still going to the pro bowl we were
still saying like how the heck is this
guy putting up these numbers with these
quarterbacks then one quarterback would
get hurt then they'll go sign another
one like where the heck they get this
guy but d-hop nothing changed he never
complained he never said anything all he
did is go out there and play football
but yet when it was time for the houston
texans to take care of him they didn't
want to take care of him they traded the
best
the best wide receiver in the national
football league to the arizona cardinals
and look what the arizona cardinals are
doing and look at what the houston
texans are doing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports